A
tracheoesophageal fistula is a birth defect
in which the esophagus has an abnormal connection
to the trachea.
The esophagus is the tube that food passes
through from the mouth to the stomach, and
the trachea is the windpipe that air passes
through from the mouth and nose to the lungs.
The trachea forms during the sixth week of
pregnancy.
Here, you can see the tube that will eventually
form all the organs of the digestive system.
The trachea and lungs grow from the part of
the digestive tube that will eventually become
the esophagus.
For unknown reasons, the esophagus and trachea
may grow and separate abnormally during this
time.
The esophagus may end in a blind pouch with
missing gaps and be abnormally narrow.
This absence or narrowing of a natural body
passageway is called atresia.
The esophagus and trachea may also have an
abnormal connection called a tracheoesophageal
fistula.
Here, we see the most common type of tracheoesophageal
fistula in a newborn infant.
The upper esophagus ends in a blind pouch,
and the lower esophagus connects to the trachea.
This is a serious problem because stomach
contents can travel up the esophagus and pass
through the fistula into the trachea and lungs.
The fistula can also cause difficulty breathing
for the newborn since air can now bypass the
lungs and enter the stomach.
Before the tracheoesophageal fistula repair
procedure, an intravenous line will be started.
The baby may be given antibiotics through
the IV to decrease the chance of infection.
The baby will be given general anesthesia
which will put the baby to sleep for the entire
operation.
A breathing tube will be inserted through
the mouth and down the throat to help the
baby breathe during the operation.
The surgeon will make an incision in the baby’s
chest, usually on the right side.
Through the incision, the surgeon will gently
move the lungs aside to view the trachea and
the esophagus.
After identifying the tracheoesophageal fistula,
the surgeon will slowly close the fistula’s
connection with the trachea with sutures,
then cut the connection away from the trachea.
The fistula’s connection with the esophagus
will also be cut, and the fistula will be
removed.
Next, the surgeon will make an incision at
the end of the upper esophagus to open it.
Then, the upper and lower esophagus will be
connected with sutures.
Finally, the surgeon will insert a surgical
drain in the chest and close the incision
with sutures.
After the procedure, the baby will continue
to use the breathing tube until they’ve
healed enough to breathe on their own.
The baby will be taken to the neonatal intensive
care unit for monitoring.
Pain medication will be given.
The baby may continue to receive antibiotics
through the IV.
Babies are released from the hospital when
they’re able to eat enough to maintain their
weight, which may be after two weeks or longer.